[Music]
you
dearly beloved we are assembled here in
the presence of God to join this man and
this woman in holy Mary which is
instituted by God regulated by His
commandments blessed by our Lord Jesus
Christ and to be held in honor among all
men to be held in honor among all men
from the world of men and women this one
man this one woman choose each other to
honor love and cherish in sickness as in
health until death do us part
what is in the heart and mind of this
girl as she pledges her thoughts her
body her life to this man respect and
admiration love and affection deep faith
and the high hope for a good life
together as man and wife and if so
blessed in time to come as mother and
father what is in the heart and mind of
this man as he pledges his trust his
body his sacred honor to this woman the
answer lies in you for the man is you
you who once stood in this holy place
and took part in the sacrament and you
who will someday stand before God with a
woman you love as this man stands today
your answer may be freely given for you
may come to this woman as she comes to
you clean and body and spirit as you
enter on a new way of life in which the
best is yet to be or you may have no
answer that can bear the light of day
for in your conscience may be hidden
closets where dead things are stored
violations of the vows you took today
this man then is you and his answer is
your answer freely given or hidden in
secret places so God created man in his
own image male and female created he
them
[Music]
and God blessed them and God said unto
them be fruitful and multiply and
replenish the earth one man one woman
sanctified in the sight of God and in
the presence of their fellow men by
sacred writ and ring as man and wife
given only to each other for ever and
ever more this is the law of God this is
the way of life for the children of God
on earth reduced to the simplest terms
and applied to us as individuals the
standard for personal conduct can be
summed up in the question how honest are
you you won't cheat cards it's a matter
of fair play and a sense of decency so
win or lose it's on the up and up you're
not a thief at heart and you hold no
truck with anyone that is
[Music]
but what about sex you men who are
married and you men who hope to be
married someday
how honesty you when it comes to sexual
indulgence in terms of the moral
responsibility to the decent women in
your life just how faithful are you in
the long ago when man and woman when you
on earth and earth itself was young
possession was permission sex was the
animal expression of primal instinct
historians of human life doubt and some
deny that earliest man expressed such
emotions as love and affection for the
mother of his children but man had in
him the spark of divinity who grew in
wisdom and he became master of the earth
he discovered in himself new evidence of
character here man began to express the
human values we call kindly friendship
attendance the relationship between
husband and wife parents and children
has developed through the centuries into
a natural expression of mutual trust and
affection the modern man living an
honour and intimately sharing and family
love brings permanent happiness to his
marriage and family life
instead of the loose talk about women
and sex you usually get in bull sessions
let's have the real logo what are the
facts about women and sex especially the
business of illicit sex
[Music]
for the most part that's what it is a
business highly organized and highly
profitable to those who run it not the
girls themselves they usually wind up
with the least in terms of money and the
most in terms of degradation and disease
where does the money go of those men who
patronize prostitutes for the Madam's
who manage the houses their cut is at
least half of anything paid to the girl
the gangsters and underworld big shots
who own the business the Vice syndicates
whose take runs in the millions every
year the crooked police and politicians
of self-protection this is the financial
pattern of prostitution money that
supports a dirty business run by the
scum of the earth defacing women and men
who use them spreading disease and
supporting political corruption
one of the chief arguments used to
justify sexual indulgence outside of
marriage is that it's necessary in order
to stay healthy and retain sexual power
more nonsense has probably been spoken
on that phase of Sexton on anything
the medical officer can give us the
correct information take his temperature
yes sir I'll be with you in just a
minute boys often you have heard it said
that unless the sex urge is satisfied
when it develops some emotional or even
physical harm will develop no
responsible physician would subscribe to
such a statement many men are told that
they must have sexual intercourse in
their late teens or have it frequently
once they have started in order to avoid
harm or even loss of their virility or
sexual power this is absolutely not true
if you want to justify sexual activity
outside of wedlock you're going to have
to find something outside of medical
grounds abstinence from sexual
intercourse has no adverse effect on a
man's health or his future sexual
ability the man who limits his sexual
experiences to loose women tends to
develop sexual habits in a frame of mind
on a low animal level such a man comes
to value a woman not for her qualities
as a fine companion a wife or a mother
of his children but only for her body
he's the cynic the wise guy who knows
everything there is to know about women
the best poem is the best place is where
you can get a cheap and maybe free but
to say what to do he'll tell you all
about it whether you're interested or
not
if you have other things to do he'll
give you a snarl of disgust with animal
insistence on fixing them up he'll take
all followers as part of the pack
leading him on the hunt for his kind of
game he has all women pegged as tramps
and push shell feed this is the
loudmouth Ladykiller and sexual athlete
who laughs at such things as theses
manners kindness love and affection
whether he admits it or not he's a poor
sucker trapped by his own sense of false
bags
[Music]
looking only for sexual bargains his
choice is limited to cheap women the man
who repeatedly uses a professional
prostitute or a sexually promiscuous
amateur that man can permanently damage
his ability to enter into the love
relationship which makes possible a
happy marriage and a successful family
life the ladies man of America that's
the man in uniform according to an
outdated legend still believed by some
men in the service the girl in every
port kind of romantic nonsense that
gives many a serviceman delusions of
grandeur about himself and his
irresistible here on
[Music]
he thinks he has a reputation to uphold
as a he-man member of the armed forces
of the USA and so every chance he gets
he's out to make a conference he likes
it when they're hard to get it isn't the
chance to show his power makes him think
he really has something this time no
professionals for this guy his women of
the free except maybe for a few drinks
and food and cab fare home
[Music]
well he's the big moment in her life and
she's his only his says he this man is
kidding himself and he needs to wise up
to the facts of life with easy pickup
one guy is pretty much like another
there's usually been someone ahead of
him enjoying the big moment he thought
was only for him this man rated with a
pickup only while he was taking his turn
but there'll be someone else to fill his
place after he's gone this is sex on the
prowl
[Music]
the intimate privacy of husband and wife
at the end of the day
[Music]
the unspoken expressions of deep
affection shared in a quiet confidence
of mutual love she belongs to him only
him and he knows he belongs to her only
her and she sure on this high human
level a man's sexual relations are
associated with respect to independence
a real concern for his partner and other
sentiments that any man has deep in his
heart for the woman he loves how you men
manage your sex life is a matter not
only for the chaplain and the doctor it
is also my responsibility as a
commanding officer for those of you who
consider it a service manager right to
cut loose on leave here's a statement
from one of our outstanding military
figures with which I fully agree I do
not excuse sexual promiscuity nor do I
consider it a necessary evil associated
with military life I consider the
greatest factor opposing promiscuity to
be proper religious and moral training
with constant emphasis on self-restraint
with marriage and family as a goal I
expect such training to be encouraged in
every practical way
[Music]
is it always a strong sexual urge that
drives a man to houses bars and the
streets in search of an easy woman in
many cases the answer is not very often
sexual desire has nothing to do with it
sometimes it's just plain curiosity he
wanted to see what it was all about to
find out if was anything like they said
it was for him it was sordid rather than
exciting embarrassing rather than
satisfying leaving him with a disgust
not only for the woman but for himself
a crawling feeling which a decent man
gets from the use of commercial sex
actually he didn't want any part of it
but he lacked the moral courage to live
up to his own principles and convictions
some things that men do were harmless
pastimes and as such they're man's own
private business but sexual relations
never belong to this class they always
affect another they involve sacred human
personality and a basic loyalty that is
one of the reasons why illicit sexual
practices are condemned by a direct
commandment of God thou shalt not commit
adultery but God never makes a demand
upon us that he does not give us the
power to meet those who obey the
commandment can continue to receive
God's strength and guidance to continue
in obedience those who have violated the
commandment can receive forgiveness for
the violation and then return to
obedience such forgiveness depends upon
the sincere desire to be forgiven and
the intent and effort to avoid further
violation by wanting it
each man can have the honor and
determination to safeguard and further
family life by his standard of conduct
each man can show the love and will to
please his creator and abide by divine
law
no one says it's easy for a vigorous
healthy man the practice control the
restraint in matters of sex but such
self-discipline is possible for anyone
who accepts it as necessary and
worthwhile
each man avoids many things that is
tempted to do it just because they
aren't worth the price of doing it's an
aid to self-control to keep a strong
sense of contact and association with
the folks at home and especially the
women who mean most to you your wife for
your mother a girl from school or your
home town when two Broke are too far
away to phone or visit the mail still
goes through binding relationships
exchanging intimate thoughts sharing
plans attendance at religious services
in the private worship of God enables a
man to strengthen his standard of
conduct by the faith of his choice
practice be acceptable adult
relationships the mixed company with its
social satisfaction for both men and
women partners at a dance of party and
evening doing the town of seeing a movie
double dates to share a car with a stop
for food to finish the evil ways of
enjoying the pleasure of the opposite
sex which will stand the light of day
[Music]
home will be a finer happier place to
come back to hence an excited waiting
will bring the welcome you want you'll
be able to greet her with a clean heart
and open a clean embrace family and
friends will be more wonderful to see
again no questions to be feared your
eyes to be avoided and no subjects which
mustn't be touched
[Music]
you'll be coming back without hidden
closets in your conscience proud of the
service your pardon and with good clean
memories of your hit unit
[Music]
one man one woman will share their love
only with each other not willing to do
anything to spoil it love this kind of
love given and a happy marriage is the
most satisfying expression of man's sex
life sanctified in the sight of God and
in the presence of a fellow man by
sacred writ and ring as man and wife
given only to each other forever and
ever more this is the law of God this is
the way of life for the children of God
on earth and to be held in honor by all
men
[Music]
[Applause]